Salut aujourd'hui on est dimanche, et c'est le jour où je vous explique quelque chose de mentalistique
pour bluffer à votre tour vos amis.
Comme je le fais de temps en temps, je vais d'abord vous le faire à vous,
à travers l'écran pour que vous puissiez vivre l'expérience et après je vais vous
expliquer comment ça se passe.
Je vais avoir besoin de lire les lignes de votre main.
Vous allez tendre votre main gauche, c'est-à-dire l'autre, celle-ci. Voilà.
Et vous la placez devant l'écran pour que je puisse bien analyser les lignes de votre main.
Attention, je vais m'approcher un peu de la caméra... ça va me faire une grosse tête !
Tout ce que je vois pour le moment c'est que j'ai les yeux proches de l'écran
et qu'il n'y a pas votre main.
Mettez là, vraiment, jouez le jeu. Jouez le jeu même que deux secondes.
D'accord...
Ca c'est intéressant...
Ca aussi...
[rires] J'ai l'impression que je louche.
Parfait ! Vous pouvez enlever votre main, j'ai tout ce qu'il me faut.
Je sais exactement qui vous êtes, je sais exactement qui tu es, toi spécifiquement toi !
Comme je parle spécifiquement de toi, je vais me permettre de te tutoyer.
Je pense, par la lecture des lignes de ta main que t'es un ami loyal, honnête, dévoué.
Quelqu'un sur qui, on peut vraiment compter, en cas de coup dur.
Je pense aussi que tu es beaucoup plus ambitieux que ce que tes amis, tes camarades, ta famille ne le pense.
D'après ce que j'ai vu sur les lignes descendantes, tu dois être quelqu'un d'assez fort, qui dégage une impression de stabilité,
alors qu'au fond de toi, il t'arrives parfois de t'inquiéter de l'avenir.
Je pense aussi que tu es assez perfectionniste, ce qui d'ailleurs pourrait énerver les gens autour de toi.
Tu sais d'ailleurs, et c'est très bien, peser le pour et le contre plutôt que de conclure hâtivement.
Ce qui fait que tu es le genre de personne qui aime bien être en possession de toutes les données, de toutes les informations,
avant de prendre une décision.
Quand tu regardes derrière toi, tu penses des fois à des choses que tu aurais pu faire autrement, mais d'une manière générale
tu n'as pas cette tendance là, tu vas plutôt de l'avant.
Bien que tu aimes le changement, la nouveauté, la variété, t'apprécies quand même une forme de routine, de stabilité,
de choses que tu connais, que tu reconnais.
Et apparemment au moment où je te parle, tu as une grande décision à prendre, quelque chose d'important
où alors tu viens juste de vivre un grand bouleversement, un grand changement.
Tu sais pertinemment que tu as beaucoup de capacités que tu n'utilises pas, et des fois tu te dis je vais le faire et puis après je ne vais pas le faire.
Et tu as vraiment deux facettes:
Tu as une facette vraiment sociable et extrovertie.
Et il y a un autre côté de toi que l'on connaît parfois un peu moins, qui est plus réservé en fait, plus solitaire en réalité.
Voilà ce qu'on m'ont dit les lignes de ta main, et je pense que c'est juste.
Un petit peu flippant non ?!
Comment ça fonctionne ? Et bien je vais vous le dire.
Evidemment ! C'est le but du dimanche !
Le texte est basé principalement sur l'effet barnum.
C'est-à-dire que l'on recadre nous même par rapport à ce que l'on est vraiment, à notre propre vie, à nos propres souvenirs à qui on veut être.
Ce texte là n'est pas de moi, il est d'un psychologue qui s'appelle Forer et qui a mis ce texte au point fin des années 1940,
pour faire un test sur des étudiants.
Il a donné ce test, pour tester l'effet barnum.
Et il s'est aperçu que la plupart de ces étudiants ont trouvé le texte extrêmement précis.
Dans "Strange face in the Mirror", livre que Caputo a écrit en 2010, il reparle de ça.
C'est "Strange face in the Mirror illusion" d'ailleurs.
On peut dire que c'est tout ce qui est applicable à tout le monde où tout le monde va se sentir concerné, en réalité.
C'est un peu comme un texte placébo.
C'est nous, mentalement, avec nos recadrages et nos propres souvenirs, qui donnons du crédit à tout ça.
Le script est assez long, et à chaque fois qu'il y a un script long, vous me dites dans les commentaires "mais pourquoi tu ne l'as pas écrit ?"
"Pourquoi tu nous l'as pas donné ?"
Je vous mets un lien dans les commentaires, c'est un lien sur mon site internet,
où je vous ai mis le script, ça vous permettra de le télécharger en pdf.
Prenez le temps de l'apprendre par cœur, ce sera beaucoup plus crédible.
Si vous ne savez pas comment apprendre un texte par cœur, regardez la vidéo d'hier, je vous l'explique.
En terme de présentation, trouvez toujours un angle:
lisez dans du marc de café, lisez dans les lignes de la main, demandez une personne de vous citer les cinq premiers chiffres qui lui viennent
et faites une analyse psychologique d'elle.
En tout cas, trouvez une motivation au départ, et vous allez voir, la personne sera vraiment bluffée.
Surtout si c'est quelqu'un que vous ne connaissez pas, peu, ou quelqu'un que vous venez de rencontrer
Je ne vous avais jamais fait d'explication de ce type là.
Si vous voulez d'autres explications, on a un signal entre nous.
En effet, vous pouvez me le faire savoir en laissant un petit...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
Une autre manière également de le tester sur vos amis, c'est de partager cette vidéo et de voir les retours qui vous ferons dans les commentaires.
En parlant de commentaires, vous pouvez en laisser un, je le lirai.
Passez un excellent dimanche, et rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !